good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it's tuesday oh it is tuesday i thought
you were going to keep going yes i did
and the song abruptly and let us know
more about tuesday and how we can expect
to be feeling so it's tuesday
for sure i don't think anyone can argue
that except maybe if you're australian
it's tuesday
it's kind of gloomy in new york and i'm
not gonna lie i'm living for it you know
what i'm thinking about on the way here
what you know people have seasonal
depression and it's like during the
winter it's like really kind of
depressing
and then the sun comes out in the spring
and you really do start to feel better
i think i have anti-seasonal depression
like i'm depressed in the summer when
it's hot and i've chubbed up and i'm
forced to wear shorts and like shame for
wearing leggings and then like in the
winter when we're all bundled up looking
so chic drinking hot cocoa everyone's
like depressed and i'm like the opposite
you're blossoming
yeah i think that's what i figured out i
think that's possible you know like
there are definitely plants that blossom
in the winter and you're just one of
them i'm a fern
you're a mc plant yes and you know what
else i was thinking about you
you're just full of thoughts so i don't
always watch the show when we get home
because
i don't i find myself to be like very
self-critical but
it's necessary because i watched
yesterday's show and we just had like a
lot to catch up on i swear to god i was
not speaking english
oh really talking so fast swallowing
entire sentences like i don't know how
anyone followed what i said yesterday
and i was talking over you like a next
level amount i'm sure you didn't even
realize because you're so conditioned
there was only one time that i realized
i know during the love island recap
um i'm not even i don't even remember so
i just
i'm just gonna be like super self-aware
today okay cool well
you know what that's this is probably
like not the right time
since you're like on this new journey
like i have a gift for you
and you would think i should give you a
gift when you've completed your journey
no i'm giving you this gift at the
outset just a little context it's not it
had nothing to do with your birthday
because i ordered it a while ago but it
got here yesterday
you were always thinking of me i am
always thinking of you because so many
things just remind me of you and so even
though i didn't get you a cake for your
birthday like
i'm thinking of you year round and you
still didn't bring that puzzle home that
i got you
and i just want all the viewers at home
to know when i went away in march i saw
a gift that made me think of claudia it
was a puzzle that
like had leaves on it and it like was
meant to be peaceful like puzzles are
supposed to be like it says the word
piece
it says like it's supposed to bring
inner peace it's a puzzle that brings
inner peace i'm like that's so claudio
so thoughtful got it for her it's still
in the studio never took it home
can i just tell you that like i've been
really vocal like in the last year about
puzzles
and so i've literally gotten so many
puzzles like it's like
like when people think of me now they
buy me puzzles i got two from ben's mom
last night for my birthday and they're
like sick jonathan adler ones
i'm overwhelmed with puzzles i
understand okay that's puzzling well
this is not a puzzle okay i have a gift
for you and is it edible
no i just saw it it made me think of you
oh my god
i hope you enjoy it oh my god i'm so
nervous oh i'll close my eyes
of course once again i did not wrap it
okay it looks appears to be a blouse
it is a blouse it's from
[Laughter]
you're kidding you guys
please can i get my camera okay maverick
athletics
now this is why it's so interesting
ready of course
maverick is a main character in my new
york times bestselling book available
now on all platforms i'm the protagonist
do you know whose company this is
logan paul yeah and like our boyfriend
over here logan paul so this is just a
multi it's a layered gift it's a layered
gift and you want it like i ordered it
when he was fighting
like that's what i mean because you saw
the i saw the
he's maverick athletic so i went to see
like his merch to see if he had anything
that had maverick on it
so much stuff was sold out but i managed
to snag this shirt okay
thank you so much this is such a so
meaningful honestly like it has so many
meanings
yeah because even if maverick wasn't a
character in the book i would have loved
a piece of logan paul merch yeah and
this is just everything of the sword it
really really is thank you so much
you're so welcome and i also think it's
a cute shirt
100 i'm gonna wear it on the show
tomorrow awesome maybe i'll pair it with
some black leggings
just a thought that's really crazy thank
you so much you're so welcome when i
came i was just so excited i've been
waiting for it to come what a bright
tuesday i need to start like
thinking of you for gifts cause it's
like a fun thing to do on the show it is
a fun thing to do on the show and it's
just like a nice thing to do for people
but
it's not like i'm like i want to get so
into a gift let me seek one out but like
i just when i see something i'm like
this reminds me of so-and-so but i have
to get it buying gifts for people like
for birthdays is
kind of hard because you're like seeking
for the moment
if that makes sense whereas like if
somebody just crosses your desk yeah
okay i'm gonna start getting you stuff
too
okay cool cool that's exciting can i put
it on the company sure but you did get
me a cake for my birthday so like we're
even in a gucci bag a few years ago yeah
a few years ago yeah um it wasn't that
many years ago
no like it was a long time we haven't
said
we haven't said gucci bag gucci bag
gucci bag gucci bag it's because we
don't have a clock right we were talking
about that last week you know what
can you put on the apple tv just like a
clock app just so
if it be when it becomes 11 11 we can
make a wish i don't even know what i
would wish for
what what did we use to wish for besides
a gucci bag um
well you know they were more so like
internal wishes anything that i would
wish for i don't think i would share
because then it wouldn't come true
and it's like really [ __ ] personal
it's so personal even though i pretty
much wish for the same thing like with
every gift and it's like
it's like a broad range i think everyone
does this of course
health happiness success for everyone
you care about inner peace yes
yeah i think a lot of people wish for
and for yourself
and harsher punishment what i always
referral violators
got it okay i always quote that line
from miss congeniality and i can never
remember what she actually said
she said for harsher punishment for
parole violators i think
i don't think that's what she says
actually i'm gonna look it up google it
and that reminds me i don't know if i've
ever shared this on the show do you know
what my um
drag name is um no
disgracey lou freebush that's great
isn't it yeah do you have one
no where would i get one you come up
with it it's not like a store
oh yes that would be harsher punishment
for pearl violators stan
very good thank you um yeah you need to
think about that
okay i will maybe challenge maybe some
people will have some good uh
retardations it has to be something with
like red
you know because your hair is red yeah
sure
we'll see i'll think about it do you
guys think about it too cool
um i was told by some members of the gay
community
that the miss congeniality reference is
a very like
hetero reference which i thought it was
like
totally a popular movie in the gay
community but i guess it's not
interesting yeah so it's not like a
totally valid drag name is what i've
heard
okay from brian so maybe you need to
rethink yours as well
yeah but i'm like so proud of the
creativity that like i came up with you
know
yeah that i'm not willing to let it go
huh i know it's good it's a pickle you
know just
you know have confidence in your choices
um
it's so hard when you have make the
worst choices most of the time you know
yeah okay how was your day yesterday it
was really good we were booked and busy
we got our patreon up the birthday blog
on patreon.com it gave me anxiety
re-watching it because i had such a
negative experience you'll see why in
the vlog
i had such a negative experience leading
up to the party for a multitude of
reasons that i
believed to be extremely valid and
that's not only because like you know i
was in my head having anxiety now
days later i was valid in my concerns do
you agree um
i do agree and watching your your
footage i found to be really interesting
and
also while i posted this on my story
yesterday while i was uploading the vlog
i was like we did a vlog for your
birthday three years ago i'd love to see
like how the vlog style has changed
since like what we
it was so like really so different
so different first of all we were so
different like the way of course the way
i look was atrocious
the way we look of course but also how
we talk i feel like every year i get
older
my voice gets less and less in new york
like i've always felt that way when i
watch my bat mitzvah video like it's so
crazy
and then when i watch videos from a few
years ago i do sound
more like a nasal long island vibe yeah
you know
so but not less new york like less long
island there's a difference that's true
there's a big difference
yeah and i'm sure people listening who
don't live in new york are like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about but it used
to be worse i'm telling you yeah like
new york
is like you know i walk in to walk in
the streets of new york and i drink lots
of water and coffee
long island but we don't even talk like
that no but like sometimes we don't even
talk like that
martin lauren's daughter was martin
lauren's daughter
born and then long island would be i
walk and i talk in the streets of new
york
and i drink lots of water and coffee
lots of water it's a subtle difference
yeah no it is different though but also
our vlog style was so
kind of amateur because we were so new
to the vlogging space and i remember
people
giving us really good feedback like you
guys just like you know filming yourself
singing is what we see on snapchat
like evolve on the vlog and it was good
advice we don't really do that anymore
and
we're obviously much better vloggers now
but it was i watched it because you told
me to watch it and it was
cringy but it was joyful and also what's
interesting is like we don't really
sing on snapchat anymore so it's like we
could go back to filming like that
times are changing because like we don't
do that stuff anymore so it was really
like cute to see just
everyone we all like really look so
different and are so different we're
just like so much younger it's real i
mean and we were three years younger but
like
you can really tell also what i thought
was cool from the video and what i took
away from it is like pretty much
everyone at that party i would still
invite to my party today
and did invite to my birthday party so
it's like i like that
i literally have the same group of
friends like years only it's only been
three years
some people like you know every year
it's new people at their party
yeah no so it was cool so if you are a
patreon member check out the vlog that
we posted yesterday and then you can
also just search birthday in the tab and
claudia's old birthday vlog will come up
and like
hundreds of other sickening videos
sickening
um so my dad was good it was busy got so
much content out yesterday's episode was
so long
so long i guess we just had a lot to
catch up on we still didn't even get to
cover
all the news that had happened over the
weekend it has spilled into today's
episode it has i'm i'm gonna just
apologize for that like
right when we wrap the show i was like
[ __ ] we forgot to talk about scooter
braun i don't know how i
like it wasn't top of my news feed but
it wasn't so we're talking about it
today but you know what i'm actually
grateful that we're talking about it
today because last night i rewatched um
lily pond studios um disney plus taylor
swift folklore and a lot of folklore
like is about scooter braun and i
actually feel like i have refreshed my
memory on
on a lot of what went on during that
time okay also
i put this on my instagram story but
when i was searching for taylor swift
and disney plus
the jonas brothers experience came up
which is a concert dvd
like montage documentary of their first
like big tour
and demi lovato did a cameo and soda
taylor swift she saying should have said
no i think that was like when her and
joe were dating and i watched it it was
so cute
and then i was just like scrolling
through it to see if there's anything
else interesting and scott borschetta
was in it
isn't that weird because of taylor no he
was with the brothers like it had
nothing to do with taylor this was like
30 minutes before
in the movie interesting yeah maybe he
was like their manager or maybe when
they were at big machine like in the
beginning i don't know or maybe he was
like scouting them
yeah it was really interesting to the
show and i was like who is that
curly-haired freak
and it's got worse shadow crazy crazy
times well i think that's a great segue
to get into the past five stories that
you do need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and that's for sure true for sure but
i'm already feeling so much better from
yesterday
and i just kind of want to keep that
momentum going to keep my rdh flare-ups
to a minimum to a minimum so today's
episode is brought to you by stamps.com
this summer is showing welcoming signs
of a more normal life ahead
finally you can get back to enjoying
life's little pleasures like smiling at
your neighbors seeing a movie and going
to the post office
not okay some parts of normal life
aren't so great but with stamps.com you
can skip trips to the post office and
save on postage
mail and ship anytime anywhere right
from your computer send letters ship
packages and pay less
a lot less with discounted rates from
usps and ups
they make it easy for small businesses
to mail and ship without needing to take
a trip to the post office
they bring all the usps and ups shipping
services right to your computer
it's an absolute no-brainer they offer
deals you can't get anywhere like 40
off usps and 66 off usps
and with their switch and save feature
you can quickly compare carriers to find
the best rates every time
stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with our promo code
toast you get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in toast
that's stamps.com promo code toast
stamps.com
never go to the post office again words
to live by
truly okay first up if last week was
about happy couple news this week
is about sad couple news yes first music
mogul scooter braun separates from his
wife yael
sources say braun who famously
discovered justin bieber and even more
famously got into a public fight with
taylor swift
has been through a rocky patch with
mining aerys yael cohen braun and they
decided to take a break
interesting factoid mining heiress go
back
mining heiress so an heiress of a mining
empire yeah well they didn't say empire
could be you know
a small business they don't just call
people aristocracy i agree i found that
to be an
interesting factoid as well and i know
that i share this interesting factoid
all the time but you know whenever i
hear the word heiress what do i think of
serena williams perfume commercials from
like 15 years ago her name backwards is
inerys
and so she had a perfume called inaris
and that's always what i think about
sorry okay thank you
jermaine to the subject completely but
insiders tell page six that in spite of
persistent rumors doing the rounds in
the music
music industry there are no plans for
them currently to divorce
they're friends and they're still living
together at the moment but
they are separated question mark oh that
was the initial report that came out and
also like based on their instagrams i
think a lot of people are confused
because they're very much posting as a
family um so it's
quite unclear well there's a few things
at play here
one um i did read somewhere that there
are some
like lawsuits going on with scooter and
like perhaps this might be like a
protective measure i don't know that's
what
one theory i don't think they would have
to divorce yes i don't know if i believe
that i don't
that doesn't add up to me now everyone
of course when you think of scooter
braun
who do you think of i think of justin
bieber okay
most recently most people think of
taylor swift yes and i know a lot of the
swifties are like quaking in their boots
you know
the master of spin has a couple side
flings good wives always know
all of that but i don't know and i'm so
firmly team taylor of course but i just
feel weird about like celebrating like
let's say this
is a divorce like have kids like we're
all like jumping for joy because like a
family's being broken apart
i don't like that are people jumping for
joy the swifties are because there's
like you know kim and kanye first and
then scooter and
alec who's next and we love
i support taylor wholeheartedly 100 i
don't
like that kind of dialogue understood
also i hate to break it to everyone but
at the end of the day like
this has nothing to do with taylor swift
no 100
so i agree i find this to be like a sad
story i think
if we can remove taylor swift from the
equation because she really has nothing
to do with nothing their relationship
or them getting divorced or living
together and separating
um i feel like a lot of people looked at
scooter and now elle is like a couple
goals for
short time because they've been together
for a while and like he has so much
success
and like you know those things change
people yeah up until now it hadn't
changed their relationship
so i i find this to be a sad story plus
they have three kids but i also feel
like based on you know this living
together thing
maybe they just like can no longer stand
each other are living in separate wings
but they're gonna
live together for their family yeah i
mean i was shocked at the news like i
never
i was shocked yeah like super surprised
yeah you know what else this is really
not a lot to do with um
these people but it made me think of
love island because i can't i discovered
another pet peeve of mine
you know how i said like i hate when
they call like them the boys island
i hate on like shows or in general when
people refer to themselves as a power
couple
same who does that in love island they
did no but did they do it
no no no i was just saying because i
said the word couple goals got it got it
um
but i just like that's just a pet peeve
no it's really illusory when people do
it but me and ben are a power couple
i'm kidding no it's literally it's
cringy it's like so cringy
simmer down sir simmer down simmer the
[ __ ] down
um so this was just genuinely shocking
news but also the reason why i brought
up watching lily pond studios is because
on the e news post where they were like
put a picture of scooter and you know i
was like you know whatever
all the comments were the master of spin
has a couple side flings goodwill's
always know
which is the line for mad woman um
it's from the bridge and a lot of people
think it has to do with taylor and
i was watching lilly pond studios and
before she performs every song she sits
down with either aaron destner or jack
antonoff and talks about the song
the meaning behind it whether it's a
story from her personal life or like she
watched a movie and wrote a song about
it
and honestly i i hear the lyrics and i
understand why people think it's about
scooter
but the way she explained it was just
more about like the perception of female
rage and was like much deeper than like
a
surface level thing that happened to her
so honestly i don't
know if i believe that that particular
line or song
is about them just stating like
irrelevant to this but just stating my
opinion
i agree and i also think i don't
i wouldn't call scooter brown the master
of spin from taylor swift's perspective
like no
there's a lot of bad blood between them
but it's not because he spinned
something in a way
and he was masterful about it if
anything he's ever having a really hard
time
spinning it back right like he came out
as a loser he's not the master of spin
i've
been something in one way i would say
that guy harvey from tmz could be
considered the master of spin
yes i would agree with that also so i
just want to put it out there i don't
think that mad woman is about
i don't think sooner right now i don't
think so either but there are rumors
going around like i think there was like
jumoi
blinds that like scooter shooting well
there were all those messages scooter
about him
and erica jane remember okay
i really feel like that's also
irrelevant to this story
it is but i just want to say cute couple
no it doesn't work for me no i agree it
doesn't work for me at all no so i just
like i want to say a message to our
swifties
um i know we don't like scooter but like
i don't really i really feel weird maybe
just because i'm a child of divorce
i don't like the weird like parading and
celebrating of a family i'll tell you
what it is
i'll tell you what it is what's going on
between scooter and taylor
is business yes and this is scooter's
personal life
yeah and i don't think that they should
be equated equated
and used against one another hundreds of
people's business were to suffer like
they could be like that's why you get
you do but dirty business you get dirty
business
but like when it has to do with his
personal life i think it's irrelevant
and i think it's just like immature to
like make fun of it so
yeah i won't i'm hoping they can work it
out me
as well and by the way one more thing we
what we know about taylor she is a
hopeless romantic like even with people
she hates i don't think she would be
wishing divorce upon people you know
i do but again it has nothing to do with
taylor
it has nothing to do with taylor even if
she was wishing it like that's not how
divorce works it's just very hard when
you're like a really invested swifty to
speak on scooter braun without literally
mentioning her name in every sentence
okay
and that's something that is my personal
cross to barry
and i to bear and i think you
you did your best and then it was like
every other sentence you think my best
was good enough
it always is good enough that's all we
ask for here they're nothing like a mad
woman what a shame she went mad
okay you guys this next story is really
shocking news perhaps more shocking than
scooter and
not even gonna lie agreed because you
know what mature was stable
he was good he was honorable until he
wasn't
until he was in southern charms naomi
olindo and mathul shah split weeks after
moving to new york city together
so i'm sure a lot of you saw this like
tweet going around yesterday that like
naomi and the tool
had split and at first i was like no
they didn't like they couldn't have it
was just a tweet and i was like there's
no [ __ ]
they just moved to new york like makes
no goddamn sense take it away
um but then it kept surfacing that same
tweet and naomi did
unfollow mature on instagram and deleted
all of her pictures with him except for
ones where there were other people in it
and now people confirms that they have
split the split has come just weeks
after the couple moved to new york city
together
quote naomi and matul are no longer
together her agent said she's back in
charleston
and plans to stay there for the time
being but
for those who don't know naomi was on
southern charm a few years ago she dated
craig conover she was like
responsible for all those iconic lines
about his sewing
career when you stop yeah you said home
and yourself
and then they broke up because craig was
you know like uh
he wasn't battling up to the battery up
to the bar and she met matul and she was
on the show for like one season with my
tool but he's like a really serious guy
he was he's a doctor
sociologist and they just had this like
really serious life and she chose him
like she
left the show to be with him have a
serious life and then
they just moved to new york and
literally the day they moved like this
tweet was going around
yeah like a week or two after they moved
so
she was in charleston this past weekend
i think for you know
her own reasons i think she had like a
friend's same thing with this
no and then i think she discovered
something that has led
her to break up with him because she
posted an instagram story addressing
what's going on
okay she posted this last night and
before i think it was all
conjecture but she posted a picture of
her looking sad with her cat
she said nothing will be worse than
losing my dad but this is a close second
betrayal is never easy for anyone so he
betrayed her
and i'm just so sorry to anyone else
that has stumbled across those terrible
messages
what are the terrible messages yeah i'm
absolutely positive i regret posting
this tomorrow but so many of you have
reached out saying you're feeling a
similar pain i'm so
so sorry yeah so it's obvious she
stumbled upon like a computer or a phone
with like dirty messages
um it's been on jumois before and i
think
jump resurfaced some of the blinds she
got um because it's now relevant that
like he was talking to an ex
for a long time seeing the ex going on
dates making out in public
so that's atrocious like that's such a
betrayal
and naomi's such a nice cool girl like i
live for her so
i'm like mad i'm obviously mad that he
cheated on her because she's a queen
and nobody deserves to be cheated on but
i'm also mad that like she really
puts so much of herself into the
relationship like she gave up
her job like her life because he didn't
like being on the show
and things that made her happy for him
and that made her happy
and then he just goes and disrespects
her like that and they moved to new york
i'm pretty sure for him
yeah his job yes disgusting disgusting
i'm so upset and i just never expected
that from a tool like i actually met
mitchell he was
a lovely man and i'm like this is so
great like it was so end game
for naomi like i never even thought
about them as right anything other than
like
riding off into the sunset yeah and now
we're just like
taking steps away from the sunset and
it's shocking we're very far from the
sunset
i'm just gonna be further of naomi i
can't imagine i just can't like her
whole world
shook the [ __ ] up shook the [ __ ] up i'm
i'm very sad for her she's such a
nice and like now i'm of course like
thinking
let's get back on southern charm like of
course yeah because she was great on the
show she was great on the show and she
has her business chaplain
that would be great for the show also
yeah with like interesting girls who
work for her
no and also like that would be great
press like for her business
and i think it's time to get back on the
show i mean maybe like not right this
second
but once she'd be right this second but
when she's ready you know so i was
thinking southern charm
is always in the news like the show is
so good
for a million reasons but also because
even when they're not on like
there's so much drama like a-rod madison
craig and paige are dating they are they
were spotted someone took a picture of
them on the street like hugging
embracing sitting on their laps like
there's something there
austin is always you know like starting
[ __ ] kristen kevin like they are such
a thomas right they are star-studded
cast like these people know
how to be famous and how to make a tv
show and be interesting like it's really
admirable i commend them
yeah very true very true yeah always
look forward to it coming back
you smell that is it smelling good
i think it's you you smell amazing what
perfume you're wearing
scent bird whatever set you may be
wearing you have good taste and you know
what you like
but great taste is also expensive and
you end up with a shelf full of
half-used bottles
or you've been wearing the same two
perfumes for years because going out to
buy a new one is a hassle
with scentbird we have found a new way
to have great taste and mix up our
fragrance routines without breaking the
bank
scentbird is a fragrant subscription
service that gives you the monthly that
gives you the opportunity to shop from
over 600 brands
it is a flexible subscription service so
you can skip any month without penalties
sendbird lets you choose a new designer
fragrance to try every month for just 16
every month you get to pick what you
want to receive so there are no
surprises and they have perfumes
colognes and a lot of unisex options
they carry top tier brands like product
gucci versace
indie labels like the harmonist and
confessions of a rebel all of the brands
are 100 authentic and if you're not sure
what type of scent you're looking for
you can sort and find a new fragrance by
brand style occasion and more
you get first of all you get amazing
fragrances but also the sizes are just
so
premium it's like nobody really needs
that big of a size and you get new ones
every month so you can keep switching it
up
or stick with the same one and it's the
travel size you just throw in your purse
take it on an airplane like it's just
it's premium with an exclusive offer
just for our listeners you can get 30
off your first month today that's only
11 for your first fragrance when a
bottle of perfume can cost anywhere from
150 to 500
even more so go to scentbird.com use the
code toast for that 30
off your first month again that's
s-c-e-n-t
bird.com free to try your first perfumer
cologne for just 11 doll hairs
side on smell amazing thank you for that
claudia thank you
so much next up jennifer lopez is going
to broadway
she will produce and star in a broadway
musical project
for tv jlo has reportedly partnered
a broadway musical project for tv which
is it
all of them jlo has reportedly partnered
with oracle scion and hollywood producer
david ellison's production outfit
skydance to develop musical projects for
tv and film
the musicals will be based on the
concord theatricals library which
includes the rogers and hammerstein
catalog
rodgers and hammerstein's famed musicals
include carousel
south pacific the king and i the sound
of music cinderella
and oklahoma where the me
if we sorry i don't know so
oklahoma where i forget how it goes but
because
i sing it when i'm around michaela me
scarella where the meeskers goes to play
that's why i saw oklahoma and
no disrespect to theater because i
really do respect the art of theater
but it was the most
atroci atrocious show i've ever seen and
you know what they did this then the
curious incident of the vlog in the
night how
how could it be worse ready i'm going to
tell you exactly how
so there's a scene spoiler alert
i don't know someone gets shot in the
show i don't know who i don't remember
and what they do is they make it like an
immersive
theater experience where literally the
entire theater becomes pitch black
and if you don't know what is going on
like if you've never seen the play it's
very alarming becomes pitch black and
there's silence
silence silence gunshot the most real
sounding gunshot i've ever heard in my
life
so i didn't know if someone gets shot
i'm in a dark theater in this climate
that's horrible
it was i literally like was in tears it
was so traumatizing i left immediately
afterwards i was so shook up i'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me they don't
give you any warning like
it was horrible horrible
i'm sorry so sorry i digress i just
it was so bad like oh my god and like
it's
it's like this immersive experience so
like if you're sitting in the front row
which i was you're sitting at like a big
dinner table
and there's like chili and cornbread and
you can't even eat it like it was trump
it was so weird
and bread yeah it was so weird yeah i
don't know i really didn't understand
the whole production like went over my
head like i was i had no idea what was
going on
that's insane i just thought oklahoma
was like 42nd street
like not it but it's the midwest 42nd
street is
everything here are the sounds of
marching of
marching feet get some tempo
on the avenue i'm taking you to 42nd
street
that's like my broadway voice you know i
mean everyone has do you have one
of course you're like quaking do it here
no because you made fun of me no i
didn't you were just off tempo
you were off tempo ready let's do it
again you hear the sounds
of mark of marching feet you're wrong
no you're wrong we'll have to check it
out yeah we'll
pull it up we'll check it out should i
pull it up they're not going to be able
okay yeah sure you have to play 42nd
street
okay youtube
42nd street opening number right
yeah i think so okay can't imagine what
the opening number isn't
hold on i just don't want to put it i
don't want to get the copyrighted sir
oh god this is like community theater
actually you can put on spotify okay i'm
here i'm here
it's a fabulous song
i'm taking you to hold on
oh this is not community theater this is
like sensational
okay i have no idea okay we'll figure it
out we'll figure it out later we can
fight about it later
let's the show must go on i can be right
later okay yeah it's never too late to
be right
same so jlo is coming to broadway um and
also perhaps on tv that just makes me
feel like it'll be something that it's
also like nbc live but
not nbc yeah i'm first of all very
confused as to what this actually is i
don't know how you make a
broadway musical for tv like is it on
broadway or is it on tv
it could be both yeah and i do find this
really interesting if she's developing
that's one thing but if she's starting
because there have been rumors for a
really long time that like jlo cannot
sing like yeah she doesn't sing live
she's had someone else singing her
vocals her entire career she's a great
performer great dancer
um but she's not like a vocalist and
vocalists go to broadway so
this might be debunking that entire
theory or she's just
more behind the scenes but it said she's
going to start she's going to star in at
least one of the projects
and also i i used to really believe that
theory
um and then i saw her perform super ball
soup no but super bowl i think you
actually do lip sync
even if you're a great talent or you can
get a you can get away with
no we saw her perform at robin hood oh
are you there no i was not there
um and i just sort of was like you know
what i'm going to let sleeping dogs eye
i'm just going to believe
j lo that she's actually singing that
she's actually singing but i also think
that maybe
throughout her career like other maybe
like there's other voices that are mixed
in with hers
but i think she can carry a tune me too
so i think she could do this i think she
can do this
well i very much look forward to seeing
the performances and finally you know
judging it for myself and letting this
conspiracy theory either
be validated or completely developed but
maybe that's why it's going to be on tv
right that's what i'm saying interesting
yeah so i'm just curious i would like
some more information on
what these projects actually are going
to be and what jlo's involvement is
going to be
yeah i'm sure that you know things will
become more clear but i just feel like
everyone's just trying to switch things
up you know and i feel like
everyone just throws jlo at every
problem and you know what
they're not wrong she does solve most
problems she does she's an icon she's a
performer her hair like i think that her
super bowl performance was one of the
best in years like she's an icon
yeah so i love that she's just being
thrown at different industries
she has a makeup thing now a hair thing
with a rod like i'm into it
i'm into it too are you ready for our
next story it's a little
real housewives casting news conjecture
conjecture because it's not being widely
reported but it's all over instagram
producers are set to act ramona singer
from real housewives of new york after
disastrous season says radar online
um a source tells radar that the only
original cast member who has never left
from day one is ramona singer but now
her time is up ramona will not be
invited back to the next season of the
show which is currently not in
production for a couple of reasons
one she's too expensive she's the only
lady that has been on the show from day
one and her salary
reflects it um plus the basic premise of
the show doesn't work anymore
a bunch of older white women behaving
badly was fun a decade ago but not today
the world has changed and if the show
wants to survive another decade it must
change too and that starts with the cast
i want to say two things
one it must literally eat luanne up
inside that like ramona's referred to as
the only og because
one season like 10 years ago luanne got
demoted to friend of and she gave it her
all and she got her job back like
it must just kill her she's not even
regarded as an og you know in my mind
she is like i
she was on the show that one season and
she did make a mark even when she was
so i just want to say yeah i agree with
devastating also i just want to say
as i was reading this quote like
real houses in new york and page six are
like intertwined
intertwined if there was a source that
was going to give casting a legit source
that was gonna give casting news
to a publication they would have gone to
page six
that makes me think that the story is
not true because the only somewhat
legitimate outlet that wrote this up is
radar online and sometimes they get it
right with housewives stuff
up until now it's just a rumor but i
think it's an interesting thing to talk
about yeah
that first of all i don't know if i
think the answer to the rhony problem is
ramona
but i do agree they had an all-time low
rating
700 000 viewers or 760 000
last week and ramona must cost them over
a million a season so if the show's not
bringing
that aspect of it i actually do
understand financially the show doesn't
make money
you get rid of the most expensive asset
i don't know
if ramona is the problem i don't think
it's just like a one-person
thing i and every time i think of like
who should be fired i'm like
well like leah but actually she's kind
of funny and she could be the future of
the show
i think ebony should stay you know i
could argue that every single one of
them here's the thing i think
individually
i would want them all to stay together
they don't work i also think that if
producers are looking at this season and
looking at the ratings and taking away
that it's ramona that needs to go
i don't think that's true either and i
also think that like
at the end of the day i think they they
have to look back on what happened at oc
and regret
firing vicki oh you think i do because
the show only got worse
and now it's so untethered and like
every season it's like
wipe the slate clean there's no like
anchor
and i think that vicky and i was one of
the people who was like it's time for
vicki to go because she approached the
show as this is my show and there's no
space for other people
and i do think that that's when it's
your time to go but look at teresa she
stays regardless also
ramona for someone who's an actual og
she doesn't
really have that attitude she definitely
has like a superiority
superiority towards like new girls in
general but she doesn't
come on reunions and act like it's her
show and she doesn't need to answer
questions
agreed i think that i think the vicky
gumbelson remark is interesting i think
their mistake
wasn't necessarily firing vicki it was
firing vicki and doing nothing else
so if they're just going to cut ramona
and think that the rest of the women are
going to be able to take the show back
to over a million ratings
i don't think that's the case like i
think that if ramona goes
maybe it's time to you clean house with
all the older women no yeah and also
when it comes and bring in like five new
people
the women who behave the worst honestly
it's sonia
like ramona we're like gets drunk on the
show and
doesn't really go off the rails or like
act in a way that's so
unhinged yeah but sonia does like the
morgan letters the
you know just this week in north fork
that's and that's like behavior that's
not interesting to watch because it's
insane it's dorinda-like behavior and
that's why yes and i don't think i
and so i agree with that but i don't
think that ramona is
the culprit of that yeah i don't know
what
maybe maybe the feeling or if these
rumors are true like maybe they're
thinking like it's just time like
everything does come to an end a lot of
ogs are being
you know nene left and then vicki was
asked to leave like
maybe that's the thinking i just don't
unders i'm curious like if the plan is
to get rid of ramona what else are we
doing
because i don't think that's gonna solve
all these problems and i also think
there's still so many spaces open on the
show there's only five
main characters right now they could
bring in three new people before they
have to get rid of someone
yeah but if the show is not having
ratings and they're like not making as
much money as they once we're like
ramona
is expensive they could offer her less
money
do you think she would take it that's up
to her yeah
that's interesting yeah like i i just i
think that this is a little premature
um but i also and it's also not valid
like it's not verified verified but i
when i read it i was like that's not
gonna necessarily make the show better
no it's not it's just it's a
it's you know it's the franchise is in a
weird space and it's in a similar
place to oc and if oc had correctly
fixed the franchise after firing vicki
there would be like some sort of
precedent to follow but there's not
what would you have wanted them to see
what would you live now in hindsight
what should they have done differently
with vicky yeah like they fired vicky
then you said they did nothing else
what should they have done then bring on
more people bring
something like they just cut vicky and
expected the rest of the group to be
enough
when the rest of the group is nothing
yeah
like that's what i'm saying if they just
cut ramona and think that the show is
going to become better with just those
four women or maybe one extra
that's not gonna do it it didn't do it
on oc yeah i think they should bring in
three new people now on oc i've heard
there's like two or three new girls
coming in
yeah it should have been last season but
there was cobid of course
if they're going to cut ramona they also
have a million other things they need to
do because ramona's not like the one
problem with the show no
not at all i and i don't really know
what the problem is but i do think it's
a it's
a not large enough cast yes a hundred
percent i don't know what the problem is
either
yeah we shall see but it once was like
one of the best franchises and it has a
legacy and it's just like
not john is part of that legacy though
so i don't know how you see there was a
time in my journey on the real
housewives where i needed ramona gone
like
me needed me over the last couple years
i've just sort of started to appreciate
her
lunacy as genuine entertainment
and so like sometimes i take housewives
really seriously
and like ramona used to really really
bother me i just thought she was like
such a two-faced like [ __ ] talking
but then you come to appreciate like
that's what this show is all about oh my
god it's 11 12 our first day with a
clock and we missed 11 11. not meant to
be not meant to be not meant to be um
so i don't know i'm torn like because i
i know what it's like to want ramona
gone i felt that way for a very long
time
but now i'm just kind of like there's
been such a lack and drama over these
last few years and she's always just
been like this
great like delusional character who we
love yeah
i agree there was a time where i would
have been cool with this and now i'm
just like i just don't think that's the
answer i don't think it's the answer
either
are you ready for our fifth and final
story is it the final story
is it yeah how did you know because i
just said it
crazy the final story
is brought to you by blueprint test prep
remember it is test taking time and if
you're not
a great study or a great test taker then
blue
print test prep is for you their test
prep delivers life-changing score
increases
on average their students receive 11
point increases for the lsat
for future lawyers a 13-point increase
for the mcat for your future doctors and
that is a really big deal
and here's how they do it they make the
boring interesting
when you are bored you don't really
retain information very well and
blueprint was founded on the idea that
test prep can actually be entertaining
and effective
they use unique animations memorable
graphics humorous pop culture references
to make your experience engaging and
enjoyable and they also have the only
dynamic study plan tool that creates
your personalized study plan at the
click of a button
your plan will outline exactly what to
study evolve with your busy schedule and
sync to your phone so you stay on track
so if we have any future
doctors lawyer toasters and you're
currently studying
switch it up blueprint test prep is the
thing for you they have elite
instructors they only hire the best
tutors
to teach for blueprint you must score in
the 98th percentile or higher for
for on on the actual exam and they turn
down over 90
of people who apply also you get really
specific analytics so after each of your
practice tax
tests the amazing analytics will help
you quickly diagnose the underlying
patterns of what you got wrong and why
to help you improve faster
they've helped over 50 000 lsat students
and over 60 000 mcaf students improve
improve and share improve their scores
um they have a 4.8 trust pilot score so
you know that you can trust them
so even if you're not taking these tests
someone in your life is
let them know like this is a truly
groundbreaking thing and then maybe if
you give them good advice they'll give
you like free legal advice after they
become a lawyer
they have an exclusive offer just for
your morning toast listeners blueprint
rarely offers discounts this big but for
the first 100 listeners of our show
we'll go to blueprintprep.com and use
the promo code toast
you'll receive 20 off that's over 200
off your lsat
or mcat class if you go to
dot com blueprintprep.comprep.com use
the promo code toast again even if
you're not studying to become a lawyer i
use this code uh for nicole
who's studying to become a lawyer so
it's really good gift for
someone in your life who's smart yeah
it's a great gift
our fifth and final story is a little
bit
of news that might sound like it'd be
good but it's actually pretty gross
well kraft macaroni and cheese
ice cream now exists here's how to get
your hands on a pint
if you dare look at it stare it in the
face oh van leeuwen
kraft partnered with new york city based
ice cream parlor van lewin to release
the limited edition
flavor of mac and cheese flavored ice
cream and yes it's made using
actual powdered cheese from their
macaroni boxes
twisted we know that there is nothing
more refreshing on a hot summer day than
ice cream
this has to be a prank right that is why
we wanted to combine two of the most
iconic comfort foods to create an ice
cream with the unforgettable flavor of
kraft macaroni and cheese we all grew up
with
this is like a piece of emoji violet
senior associate brand manager for craft
as big fans of van lewen we knew they'd
be the perfect partner to create the ice
cream with us
good question i actually have heard no i
don't know if anne lewin's vegan
mac and cheese lovers who are brave
enough to try the frozen tree can score
a pint on july 14th
beginning at 11am i know claudia will be
first in line on the company's website
but be prepared to shell out some dough
as one pint costs a whopping 12
however if you're in new york city like
claudia you can try the ice cream for
free
while supplies last at an ice cream
truck stationed in union square from
11am to 6pm
so i have something controversial to say
outside of this because i'm pretty sure
this is a prank right
like no i don't think it's a prank like
it's going down tomorrow
at 11 a.m should we go live like down at
the ice cream truck
i honestly i don't think vomit i will
like
you guys we'll post these pictures
they're wrong and these
pictures are wrong i i mean
so i'm an ice cream lover for a rubber
file connoisseur some would say and
i have something really like
controversial to say i don't like van
luins
yeah there's like a couple ice cream
places in the city mostly downtown like
there's
lines around the corner when there's
like a perfectly good tasty delight like
right across the street or like a 16
handles like
a haagen-dazs or cold stone yeah like
i'm not into this whole like reinventing
fancy expensive ice cream when it's
literally all just the same you know
and so like i just if i see this like a
line of people waiting outside van
leeuwen there's like
a tasty across the street with not one
person in it like i'm going to taste it
you know
of course i i don't recall ever
specifically trying van lewin but i know
that
i feel like i tried it once and i was
like this is what everyone is raving
about
yeah and i just feel like it's this kind
of like i don't know if this is the
right word like this
gentrification of the ice cream
experience like
making it more expensive more fancy when
it's like ice cream experiences should
be like like you were a kid you know
wearing flip-flops and it's the cone is
melting in your hand like
it's not that serious you know it's not
like this artisanal craft like
it's ice cream yeah so these like fancy
places with their fancy foreign names
like
red mango you know that's where i'm at
you can find me at the local 16 handles
yeah i mean i'm really into cold stone
creamery i feel like the best
it's a lost art 100 carvel
stunning stunning like i'm just into the
like you know like old school like
americana
local ice cream shop yeah kilwins yeah
so you guys are these fancy like i feel
like big gay ice cream is really good
though because it's so
just ice cream big ice cream i don't
loop in with those fancy
me neither but like milk bar too they
make it like milk yeah it's just like
ice cream did not need to be reinvented
and there doesn't need to be this like
upper echelon of like
fancy creameries you know they're just
an ice cream shop you know yeah
it's like a mulch shop i want to go to
pops yeah but what about pinkberry
see that's interesting i think pinkberry
is kind of
the cornerstone of these like two
because now pinkberry is like this
disgusting yeah chain and like you
literally
it's like it's like a starbucks like
it's disgusting it's like smelly and
dirty
and no one's ever in there but at one
point they like kind of started they
started this trend
like elite ice cream trend so
they kind of became their own like their
own demise
yeah because all these other fancy
better chains started popping up and
they just became like a shitty local
regional chain yeah but sometimes it is
good still it's not
it is but if you would never have liked
it because it's tart well not anymore
when it first came out i was like
everyone is quaking over this tart it
literally it's greek yogurt it was
disgusting i tried it once i'm like this
is not ice cream
this is a salad like it was disgusting
then they
they grew because they have chains
everywhere and then they have like
chocolate peanut butter vanilla
instead of plain tart and it's just like
subpar ice cream and you get
so little toppings it's like you think
you're getting a lot because you get to
choose three
you get a plastic spoon you get wrinkles
you know what the best is that most
people won't even know what i'm talking
about because it was a
very small chain in the city i think
they maybe had two locations i don't
even know if you can call that a chain
off the wall yeah do you remember yeah
that was like 16 handles
where there's like 16 handles and you
just load up 16 handles has a quality
control problem because they blew up
really fast and now every single one is
like a
dump like yeah there's raspberries on
the floor kids running around like it's
just like that's poison berry see it's
like
boys embarrassing this yeah it's very
sexy they're good
yeah that is a good premise but not in
not in a
covet world you know what's an
underrated franchise i really hope you
know what i'm about to say
come on read my mind is it new york
it's like an old school franchise
not haagen-dazs no baskin robbins no
it's not like a brand name like that it
might be like a regional thing
how regional are we talking give me like
a local
just give it to me okay we have been to
one in long island and also up by camp
come on i'm trying to think i'll give
you a clue ready
t cby yeah
the country's best yogurt like very
underrated
there's so many i think they shot
themselves in the foot when they named
themselves the country's best yogurt
because they're not
and it's also weird like where do you
want to go tcpy like it's not really
like
it doesn't roll a lot of time not at all
but it's pretty bomb
it is there are so many great options
really and this definitely makes me want
froyo
yeah i just wanted to put it out there
my thoughts on the upper echelon of ice
cream creameries
thank you for your thoughts and so what
are your thoughts on just
kraft mac and cheese which is one of
your favorite food groups it's
disgusting
flavored ice cream i feel like maybe
there people who will like this are
pregnant and like having weird pregnancy
cravings because i can see someone being
like mac and cheese and ice cream you
know
i don't think so no i want tic tocs
where people are eating like
trying out the most popular pregnancy
cravings and what are they
like bread and ice cream pickles and
peanut butter like
so it's these opposite things okay bread
and ice cream isn't that crazy but
like peanut butter like ice cream
sandwich literally with bread
that's freaky yeah but it's like these
opposite things pickle
and so i feel like this is literally the
epitome of a craving
mac and cheese uh actually they're both
like dairy no it's weird
cheese and milk i want mac and cheese
for dinner ice cream for dessert it's
not like you know
you got to put it all in a blender yeah
now we're in a blender
um so those are the best side stories
and i definitely feel as though you
needed to know some of them
i think you needed to know all of them
really for sure anything else you want
to like chat about there's no tv recap
because we don't watch the bachelor but
if you're looking for
a bachelorette recap of katie's episode
from last night
our podcast the snatcher which is hosted
by our sister margot
is available now so check it out she
does a recap with her co-host nicole and
it's fabulous
it is quite fabulous and tonight we've
got love island and the real housewives
of new york
and we will be recapping that in
tomorrow's
tv recap along with dear toasters our
advice segment so it's not too late to
get your advice
your submissions queries
submissions yeah to get your submissions
in dear toasters gmail.com if you want
us to read any on-air submissions
talking about your love life friendships
work stuff anything
dear toasters gmail.com we'll always
keep it anonymous thank you so much for
listening to today's show
that's it right that's it that's our
show really thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast accessories that you need to
know every monday through friday and
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please don't forget to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify institute public radio by
everybody today
box all the places whoever listens
vodka's finest morning joseph us to
review a bit of beautiful smile here
hope you guys have a great day we'll see
you tomorrow for
help day bye
you